have either you been ever good at like
bartering or whatever i love doing it
uh like i've learned to do it just
because my dad was really good at it
right like i [ __ ] suck at it man like
this is why i love japan where
everything
is labeled and priced because whenever i
go to thailand
you just you just play this dance around
everything you buy man
because it's a it is a [ __ ] dance
where you're just like oh okay so you're
gonna you're gonna
you're gonna charge me that well i'm
gonna like say a price that's 10 times
lower
in australia it's like a dance that you
will only dance if you decide to enter
the ring
it's like you can stand back and just
kind of be like oh this is how much you
want all right and put your wallet out
but then you can also be like
hold on let me roll up my sleeves real
quick let's sound the baby come on
because like my dad was so [ __ ]
because my dad was has been like an i.t
salesman for the past 30 years so this
man i don't know how the [ __ ] he did it
but i remember like
when i was in like uh high school or
something and
i wanted to buy my first guitar right
like a proper electric guitar
and he bought me like this like really
nice epiphone guitar which is worth like
two grand or something jesus yeah and he
looked at it and he's like
so this is just the guitar right and the
guy's like yeah he's like
can i have a chat with you mate and he
and he took the dude
like back behind like the counter into a
room right he's like hold on son i'm
just gonna
[ __ ] beat him up i don't know why did
he have to go
in the back why could he do it at the
counter i don't know i don't know but he
like took him to the bag he's like
alright let me talk
and then i think i think maybe like 10
minutes later he came out
it's pretty it's free like he came out
he came out ten minutes later and he's
like all right so the guitar now is 1500
and he threw in a free amp
and i'm like how wha what did you say
what did you
what did you do how did you do he's like
i just talked to him mate i'm like
no no no no no like if it was that easy
then
everyone would be getting deals it's
it's not just a matter of oh i just
talked to him
like what did you say to him everyone
can tell more than that yeah
yeah yeah i was like i was like what did
you say did you do a [ __ ] jedi mind
trick was it like
that's that's technically talking isn't
it did you like inception like plant the
seed
he's just like it's 1500 now the first
time i ever saw like bartering
happened i was like my mind was blown i
was like wait you can go against the
price that's written
yeah you can do it's an option because i
was in like we were on a school trip to
new york it was like the first time our
school ever like went to a different
country
yeah and um i really wanted to go to new
york for school yeah dude it was chaos
it was pure [ __ ] holy [ __ ] [ __ ] lucky
how old were you
uh 16 i think oh my god wow it was an
absolute
mess bro [ __ ] the the only the only
school trips i went to was just like
france at most that was the first that
i've ever gone to that was like the
booziest one and for some reason for one
year they never did it again i think
they realized it was a horrible mistake
yeah they took us to new york it was a
[ __ ] mess
it was awful it was like i mean if i was
a teacher that would have hated it yeah
i had a great time but
it was i remember it was very expensive
but we stayed in like really [ __ ]
sketchy motels i can talk about it more
after the story but
we were we were basically like i really
wanted converse because obviously when
you're like 15 16 you see this [ __ ] on
like american tv you're like you're on
conversation
yeah so i went to a store and my friend
was with me and
he was only he was in the year above me
and i was like man i want to get these
but i've only got like 30 bucks left and
they're 40 bucks he was like oh i'll ask
him if we can do it for 30.
he's like 17. bartering with him and
then eventually he he said
i'll give you for 30 if you give me a
two dollar tip and i'm like is that okay
are you allowed to do that i don't know
if he's the owner or what
but that's what he got it down to and i
was so impressed right when i went home
to the uk i tried to do it but
immediately all the stores were like
no wait what store was this i'd go to
like
in america or the uk in america it was
like a [ __ ]
official store i think it was like in a
mall it was like an independent store
maybe i think that's why i got away with
it so i went to like a [ __ ]
supermarket in the uk
go to the thing go to [ __ ] tesla yes
like
you're selling me this kellogg's [ __ ]
creams for like how much
i'll be like you know it's a little
three pounds a little expensive yeah
could you do 250. i'll do 250. i'll do
it i'll give you 250. she's like no
no i'm like oh okay [ __ ] i know that i
never tried it again for a while
but i like going to places where you can
do it because i like i like trying to do
it
i don't often i don't i don't know how
like
i i probably could do it if i really
wanted to
but i'm always just so [ __ ] afraid to
do it as well because i don't know how
like um i don't know because with that
kind of stuff if you're not coming in
with confidence
you're basically [ __ ] right because
there's no way you're gonna win it you
you need to come in with like a winning
mentality with like the
legacy energy i'm like i can do it it
just takes
so much [ __ ] energy but whenever
you're in a place in like thailand
that's like
90 percent of the stores you go to and
you just want a store
where you pay the price that they
originally asked for and just not have
to like
do this mini game every time i i
remember i watched like the there's a
i think i mentioned him on the youtuber
episode he does videos about prague and
he covers like taxi scams
i was in prague yeah i had a taxi yeah
and i was like this is like in the
simulations this is exactly what he
spoke about
because they were trying to charge me
what he said was being overcharged yeah
i remember i was with my maintenance
actually i'm like no
i've seen the youtube video i've got
this that i'm like i'm not paying that
that's too much
and eventually we got like half the
price it was like wow you're supposed to
be like he shows like 50 euros for like
uh
the equivalent and check money for like
um like
it was supposed to be like half that it
was like only like a 20 minute like 15
minute journey
where i was like no i've seen the
simulations i know this is right
and there's youtube channels of dudes
who go around india like bartering
oh yeah dude i can imagine
bathroom in india is just like next
level that's like that's like expert
mode
it's literally it looks like a reality
tv show with every purchase the guy's
like i'm walking away
i'm going i'm not getting in your taxi
and then i'm like [ __ ] following them
please please sir